hello hello everybody my name is
markiplier welcome back to destiny
rebellion now as you know I'm playing
lazar and as you know Lazar has a voice
but I don't want to do that voice
because it's quite oh no oh I wanted the
optional area I'm actually curious if
I've missed any other option areas
because I've kind of been going through
this game rather quickly and there were
tons of optional areas that were in the
original town in Chapter 1 but I'm not
so sure about this one
anyway lazarre's gonna continue forward
trying to find the last golden eagle and
this place it's just a life--all one
thing that I do notice is the Czar is a
little bit slow
oh these giant webs of fleshy doom
they're no match for my claw of
Destruction and my lure of destruction
haha nothing is a match Weaver George
claw of destruction that's war Santa not
Lazar
how is lazarre's voice I've totally ever
forgotten I did it like five minutes ago
and have no idea no that's what's that
close I have no idea well I hope that
that human finally I don't know why cuz
this is emulating is jaws way way way
down here well I hope that that human
meets an untimely demise at the hands of
a monster right maybe I'm gonna mean the
monster maybe I'm gonna meet a friend
all I know is that I'm very slow I can't
even run which is stupid oh boy
tasty hands with which to snack on
hopefully people will remain my
sustenance until I need it here's my axe
of doom oh those we're not there two
seconds ago well am I just riddling with
myself those who are not there I glanced
there just two seconds ago if anybody
reads this letter I want to warn you
this place is occupied by savages keep
running don't turn around
these are the humanoid arm cutters they
have no reason they don't feel pain fear
nothing don't lose your mind and stay
focused
they're probably stalking you right now
well they're gonna be in for a surprise
because I am also a monster of deathly
armed cunning one
Oh arm cutters they want to cut your arm
off quite literally well that that's
delightful that's so nice and clever of
them I hope that they fall in a pit and
die yeah you heard me
Oh God I cook Oh God aah they're
everywhere
it's a goddamn nightmare huh I look away
for two seconds
and all the sudden they're right in
front of me you son of a [ __ ]
I see you up there Oh No oh they cut
their own arms off that's what that was
all about go away go away
Jesus balls they're not doing much
damage to me they're trying to cut my
arm off what Mike arm is strong
grab my strong arm dip it in the
magazine you staring moving to them I'm
making a lot of references god damn it
actually not a lot files do let me let
me try to make them
okay pardon me for a second there let me
try to make this the episode of
references just the flight is the poops
there I'm referencing my own video I did
surgeon simulator part 3 on the iPad for
the teeth surgery just the slider side I
don't think I can ah [ __ ]
bass yet oh [ __ ] this is like you throw
one wrench into my plans and then a
complete other one oh this is good
what happens if I just go over this I
can again hi pretty sure I don't know if
I should help that humanoid bastard
George because I'm a monster cause I
mean that I don't have humanity that's
what this whole deal is all about right
also I didn't really have a choice
because the other choice seemed to be
death falling off into a pit of death
Mortal Kombat fatalities style with the
spinning blades at the bottom of that
pit in world combat 3 or 2 I don't
remember
try to reference guys I don't really
have that many references hmm Lazare do
you have the last golden eagle statue I
don't know
I took some hits of LSD yeah I hope you
all will trust me a little bit more
we both want to leave this place ok
let's open the door and enter the castle
I have some bad news
why bad news why why do you have bad
news I would like to know why it seems
kind of important destroying if it no
cake Oh
claustrophobia what now
I don't know listen this castle probably
contains a main control center of the
whole goddamn universe there are these
three entities you aristocrat the
Harlequin and their smitty werben
jaegerman jensen they're waiting for us
me sure what now
I don't really know let's just keep
going forward and see what happens
oh no I vanished oh I've gone on my own
cuz I'm a monster
douche craters No congratulation for
mythic making this far you are not very
far from finishing this this is a short
summary of the story so far if you have
any problems understanding it oh okay I
I think I got this together Ralph here
I'll summarize it myself some douchebag
wanted to travel in time he went forward
instead of backwards and ran into this
monster who's questioning his own
humanity even though he's not really
human so he smacked his call up the butt
of several human humans and then he went
back in time to this area where he was
supposed to go and then they met up in a
cross-dimensional platform of the
universe where smitty werben jaegerman
sentient is kind of a douche but they
ran up with tiny box teman he's actually
the master of the universe
boom story done I don't know whatever if
you want to pause the video and read
this you can but no karna you are doing
a fantastic job and I appreciate
everything that you have worked to this
point
it's really you feeling a little seasick
fill a little sick there I know this
water moving in front your face ain't so
good but toughen up soldier you're
almost out of here so I wonder if the
last Easter egg is somewhere around here
more aqua Fateh if I was a monster that
would do real good for me oh god damn it
you startled me
you startled me Smitty how dare ye I'm
gonna laugh when I get to the end of the
game and it's just like a little
itty-bitty cloak on tiny box Tim he
turns around at a grand piano where he's
just playing some operatic music and he
just turns out I think it was me the
whole time ha ha ha ha god damn it
everyone's getting sick here I'm sorry
man we are almost to the end of this
just keep it together just a little bit
longer this is a little bit stronger the
place Oh who's gonna clean that up oh
god man come on oh all right fine I know
you get some bad sushi or one nut it
just fine whatever
Scott damn it man keep it together I'm
gonna come in there man Jesus are you
okay are you all right God you don't
look good all right final oh god I'll
check back with you in a few minutes I
gotta go take care of some things
wait a minute where the hell did I come
in oh I get it I came at home oh okay I
see how this is I got it I'm with it I
used to be with it but then they changed
what it was inside the giant mysterious
castle
mmm now that is giant in mr. wall okay
why why is that a super jump railing oh
my legs went through my ass yeah
messing up your [ __ ] mess it up your
[ __ ] Schmidty Oh what do you think of me
now I apologize sincerely I don't
apologize
nothing it seems like a big castle I'm
wondering if I actually can do this in
one part I don't think so there's a lot
of doors here but none of them seem to
actually open so I'm wondering if it's
just a straight shot to the end hello
salud soldiers don't get sick on my
shoes please I just bought new ones
there are things that are never supposed
to happen there are things that may
happen in the know things that must hey
man oh hi Smitty what are what are these
Papik exactly what I thought this is not
good how do you know all of this Ralph
these are the aristocrat the Harlequin
smitty werben jaegerman Hanson she's
meeting where B [ __ ] man Jetson is a
reference from Sponge Bob
what do you mean these were just puppets
at the time and all the time one
superior entity was pulling the strings
all the time the one who knows
everything sees everything and controls
everything
one mastermind why do we do I don't know
but it looks like our host already knows
he wanted to meet us so we would visit
him and ask him what he wants he tiny
bug him it's not is it but I really want
it to be I really would
you are so beautiful thank you I worked
hard on my complexion and I've been
working out Oh Smitty I see you got your
two allies there good for you what the
hell happened to you the your strap you
are some funky bastard that I don't want
to know with legs for arms what the hell
that's pretty clever that's pretty
clever let's use this elevator indeed
we're gonna find out tiny bikes Tim hey
Lazar I guess I should tell you
something I have really bad feelings
when using elevators probably because of
rule number three of the horror game
rule book why did you two tell me sooner
no it started the walls are getting
closer and closer talk here is how it's
gonna happen
oh no Lazar where are you don't leave me
here oh I'm in a box of emotions acre
man dot dot dot dot dot
Oh everything's green oh oh I mean it
stayed of cross the phobia oh my god
claustrophobia part it's not optional
but you have the possibility to skip it
if you don't like this kind of level or
are in a hurry
why would I skip it come on developer I
know yeah I know you're giving a lot of
options but come on
have faith in your game this is gonna be
awesome I know that it's gonna be
awesome
I know it's gonna be awesome I know
these things it's gonna be fantastic
oh sorry oh my god this is trippy as
balls oh my goodness oh I can't move
oh god this place is your inner world
your sanity has been destroyed by
claustrophobia your current sanity level
is less than 5% you can barely move
restore your sanity by putting five
corrupted mental blocks to where they
belong
well this is gonna be fun I can't wait
tears is actually gonna be fun can I go
oh my goodness my feet have turned into
molasses I'm running like that Depa like
they squid on LSD
except it's not LSE what's the drug that
slows you down instead of speeds up
sorry I only got to LA here just a few
weeks ago I'm not up to my super drug
miss yet good god movement speed
increased jumping enable that is that's
nice that is very nice you know I'm very
allergic oh I can't I hope it's down
there because I can't exactly do
anything else besides that
what huh Hey
- speak up Sonny I don't understand you
where's this supposed to go what what oh
no I got it stuck I think I goofed I
think I goofed real bad real bad god
this level design reminds me of portal
this trickiest balls I'm sorry okay I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
Bhoomi speed increased Ed's interaction
enabled climb the edge and continue okay
cool
I'm gonna continue right over here so
what am I supposed to do with this wall
I have no idea but I'm running out of
time we're a bit after oh that ain't
good
who's back there what is wrong with you
what is wrong with you that's all I have
to say about that good golly Miss Molly
you're not wage girlfriend I mean Molly
but II mean person now you can move
freely okay no longer prison okay-dokey
oh hi baby faces you're okay okay all
right I think I'm going I think that's
good
bill is too cool are you kidding me
this is gonna pass off as if nothing
happened that was amazing
oh my god anyway I'm all that time for
this episodes but that's a good place to
stop oh my god my mind is blown right
now it's it so anyway all right thank
you all so much for watching I'll finish
this game I think in the next episode
but anyway thanks again and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye
[Music]
[Music]
just the gentlest of realism is not
exactly what we're going